PROFESSOR: All right,
let's get started.
If you haven't already, there's
two handouts on the left,
and you should take
two pieces of paper.
So we'll doing some
actual origami folding.
We'll be folding 6.849
today, just like this.
It'll only take us
eight hours or so.
This is the Jenny
and Eli folding
you've seen on the poster.
Pretty awesome.
No, we'll be folding
letters more like this.
So thanks everyone for
giving so many cool questions
and comments, and the
feedback is really helpful.
I didn't know what I was
going to cover this class.
I had too many ideas,
and your questions really
helped narrow it down
into exciting thing.
So the structures
going to be, I'm
going to go through
questions, so it's
a funny kind of interactivity
where there's a whole day
in between where you
ask the questions
and where I answer them.
But feel free to ask more
questions, follow-up things.
But there's a lot already
here, so it should be fun.
These are not questions
but funnier comments.
If you like double
rainbow jokes,
this lecture happened
a couple months
after the double rainbow fiasco.
There's a lot more, as I recall.
It was a running theme
throughout the whole semester,
so look out for that.
I know this is entertaining.
I'm getting used to listening
to myself at double speeds.
This class definitely
is nice in the way
that with a fairly
simple technique
you can prove a very
powerful theorem.
Sorry, I just remembered I
need to push a different button
here.
That's hopefully a theme
throughout the class,
but definitely
especially nice here.
It is cool, though,
strip folding,
it was an open problem for
a couple years, at least,
of no one thinking, how
do we fold any shape?
That seems really tough.
The point of the
strip folding approach
is that once you
have the right idea,
to start with a really
long rectangle, somehow
it becomes easy.
There's still a lot of details
in getting that to work,
but it's kind of neat
how that works out.
Now we get to actual proposals.
So folding practice, I was
planning on doing this,
but-- this is an explicit
comment to that effect.
So we're going to fold some
letters of the alphabet.
You have in your
packet instructions
for making the individual digits
six, four, eight, and nine,
which are all pretty easy.
You also have a diagram for this
crazy design called Typeset.
This same folding
can make any letter
of the alphabet and any digit.
So just to show
you what they will
look like these are my foldings
of six, eight, four, and nine,
according to the
first set of diagrams.
And then this is my folding
of, I think the number six,
out of Jason Ku's design.
So if you wanted
to reconfigure it,
to-- I guess eight is kind
of hard-- let me do four.
OK, so for four we've
gotta fold this guy under.
Fold this here, this tab,
I think goes back here.
So the advanced origami
folders in this class
can definitely do
Jason Ku's design,
but it takes a little while.
There, I've got a four.
Got it?
A little hard to
hold in position,
but, at least in theory, it
will make any letter all out
of one folding.
You just have to move
all the tabs around.
So it's kind of neat, but it
takes at least half an hour
or so to fold that,
unless you're really fast.
So I would recommend--
pick one of these.
Work in groups if you like.
If you want you can
form a group of four,
and make six, eight,
four, and nine.
Follow the diagrams.
This is an exercise of following
diagrams, one of the other.
We'll only have time to
maybe make one digit each,
but have fun with it.
And if you have questions,
raise your hand.
I can tell you, the first
step in six, eight, and nine,
is to make an
eight-by-eight grid.
There's a lot of ways to
make an eight-by-eight grid,
but an easy one is shown here.
So you take your sheet.
You fold the bottom
edge to the top edge--
I think they want to do it
white side up-- so they're all
valleys.
We align those edges.
You'll get a nice bisector.
Then you repeat, folding the
bottom edge to the middle.
And once you do that, to
save a little bit of time,
you could then fold that new
bottom edge to the middle
again.
That will do
eighths on one side.
It's a little bit
inaccurate, because you're
folding through two layers--
but it's a little faster.
Time is of the essence.
Then you do the same
thing on the bottom,
and you'll get eighths
in one dimension.
But then you have to fold it in
eighths in the other dimension.
Once you have eighths,
it's like three steps.
It's really easy.
For six, eight, and nine--
Four uses a different approach,
it's a little more free hand.
If you want to be more
creative, try the four.
You've got to eyeball what looks
and feels good for number four.
So out of curiosity,
how many people
have an eight-by-eight
grid at this point?
Who wanted to?
Cool.
So that's the top half
of these diagrams,
the eight by eight grid.
Then it's mostly folding
up over individual edges
and some corner
faults, but they're
all simple folds in this world.
So you're folding through, I
think, always all the layers.
Oh, no.
This is only folding
through one layer.
But these would always fall into
the some layers, simple folds
category.
So for example, make a six.
Fold this bottom edge up.
Fold the left
three squares over.
Fold this corner up.
Fold this corner down.
And fold this down, this over.
There's a really big six.
And these numbers are all pretty
much proportioned correctly.
The four, you have
to be-- it helps
to have a reference model
of one of the other digits
to make it the right height, but
it'll end up roughly correct,
anyway.
The eight's a little bit
narrow in this design,
slightly narrower
than six and the nine.
But otherwise they're
nice compatible digits.
There's a whole alphabet
on the website that's
linked from this slide,
so you go check it out.
Origami club.
So it's kind of fun to think
about font design and alphabet
design.
There's actually a lot of
origami alphabets out there.
This is one of the simplest.
It has digits.
Anyone have questions?
How many people folded
a letter, a digit?
OK.
You can keep folding, but
maybe I will continue on.
It's going to be a
lot of fun crackling.
Anyone folded this one?
Anyone working on it?
A bunch of people, cool.
Let me know when you finish.
It's kind of fun.
It's not that hard.
AUDIENCE: Yes, it is.
PROFESSOR: I wanted to point
at the OrigaMIT website.
OrigaMIT is the origami
club at MIT, and at the top
you see a different alphabet.
This is a four-fold
alphabet designed
by Jeannine Mosley
who's an MIT alum
and came to this
class two years ago.
And so that's the
reference design in 2002.
I'm not sure if it
has digits, though.
At least, the diagrams
we found for the letters,
do not also have digits.
So I think an
interesting challenge
is to design a
four-fold digit set
to complement her letter set.
If you're interested, that could
be a cool project to work on.
Folding design,
minimal fold alphabets.
You could try a three-fold
alphabet, two-fold alphabet.
Also on this website are
the meeting schedules.
It always Sundays, sometimes
2, sometimes 3 o'clock.
You should check it out.
And there's a
convention coming up,
our very own origami
convention on October 27th.
Jason Ku wanted me to remind
you about that coming up.
Even if you've never
done origami before,
other than today, you
should check it out.
It'll be fun, lots of different
sessions, from simple models
to complicated models.
This is a cool design by
Brain Chan, another MIT alum.
It's one square paper folded
into the Mens et Manus logo,
but, here, instead
of the oil lamp,
you've got a little
origami crane.
Cool stuff.
So we proceed on
to other questions.
This is a pretty simple one.
At the top of the notes, it says
folding, AKA silhouette folding
and gift wrapping, it has
a couple of references.
So where do those terms
come from, is the question.
And one answer is it's the title
of the paper, "Folding Flat
Silhouettes and Wrapping
Polyhedral Packages,"
but that's not the real answer.
So this is the two of
us and Joe Mitchell.
It's also, I think, the
introduction of the term
computational origami,
but those terms
come from earlier references.
So in that paper, there's a
sentence, classic open question
origami mathematics,
and we don't really
know where it came about.
But it was first formally
posed by Bern and Hayes
in this SODA '96
paper, which we'll
be talking about in the
next lecture, lecture three.
And this is a quote
from their paper,
"Is every simple polygon, when
skilled sufficiently small,
the silhouette of
a flat origami?"
The point of saying
the word silhouette
is that when you fold something,
like this number six--
there's a whole bunch
of layers, and there's
a lot of complexity
to this folding.
By saying silhouette, we just
mean, collapse all layers,
ignore the coloring, and
just take the outline.
So the silhouette of this
thing is a rectangle.
And, in general, that's
sort of the transformation
to throw away the complexity
of the folding, and say,
I just care about the shape.
Can I get the desired shape?
There's some other interesting
questions here, though,
which haven't been
fully addressed.
How many creases are
necessary to fold?
We'll actually get to
that in a later question.
How thick must the origami be?
The strip method
shows this if you
start from a rectangle of
paper, the number of layers
can be very small.
I think two or three is enough
for all the gadgets that we
use, probably three .
If you start from a
square, though, we
don't know the answer
to that question.
And in practice, folding
through many layers is tough.
So that is a silhouette problem.
The gift wrapping
problem, the motivation
is you have a weird-shaped gift.
You want to wrap it
with a piece of paper.
And this is posed
to us in a talk
by Jin Akiyama at a Canadian
geometry conference.
Jin Akiyama is a
really cool guy.
He has had for many, many years
a mathematics TV show in Japan.
And he's known throughout Japan,
because everyone in school
watches his videos.
And it covers really
interesting mathematics.
Some of the results
in this class
are actually in
his videos as well.
It's mostly in Japanese, so it's
a little hard for most of us
watch.
But there's some
subtitled versions,
and they're really fun.
Maybe we can have a movie
night, and watch one of them,
if I get permission.
So there isn't a great
reference for that.
I mean, he's written some
papers about different kinds
of wrapping problems, but
mostly it was this talk
that he gave in 1997, which is
when I was just starting out
in computational geometry.
That's where the
terms come from.
A lot of words.
Have you ever actually
folded a model
using this method of zigzagging
and folding with the strip?
Any real or sensible or
pretty origami models,
or is it purely for the
sake of universality?
My knee jerk reaction was,
no way is this practical.
This is just for universality.
And the point of this theorem
has always been, in my mind,
to prove that
everything is possible,
but then the challenge
is to find good foldings,
for some notion of good.
But, actually, there are a bunch
of examples of strip folding,
not a lot of different folds,
not terribly many gadgets,
but there's some cool things,
especially with strip weaving.
These are just a few examples
of woven colored strips.
You can make fun things
like Space Invaders.
You could weave
together baskets,
and wrap your
packages, and so on.
This is a little
bit more origamic.
So there were no
real folds in there,
except at the edges of the cube.
This one is a modular origami.
It involves a bunch
of different folds
to get all the pieces
to lock together.
Modular origami means you have
a bunch of identical pieces.
They kind of weave
together through folding,
and then you can make
a nice little crown.
This is a very classic model.
You've probably
seen at some point.
Here that the paper's
slit, and then it's woven.
But there's some
folds down here.
Not a lot of folding, but
strips are pretty neat.
You can definitely use them in
all sorts of different designs.
Here's some more
sculptural designing models
from taking strips of paper.
This has no glue
in it, so I think
there's more strips at the
end locking this together.
And this guy, Zachary
Futterer, took
a bunch of these kinds
of units and started
weaving them together to make
really complicated shapes.
So you can definitely do cool
things with strip folding.
And another common
one around these days
is taking gum or candy
wrappers, and folding them
down into little strips
and weaving them together
to make handbags
and other things.
This has become kind
of a fashion trend
over the last few years.
So those are things
you can do a strips.
We have used it in one paper
where the goal is actually
to be efficient and use
a small piece of paper,
and not just prove some
universality result.
This is in our paper, folding
a better checkerboard,
which we'll talk about
in two lectures, if I
recall correctly,
in more detail.
But this is sort of a baseline.
This is not the better method
that's developed in this paper,
but it's the starting point.
You take a square, so this
actually starts with a square.
You do this pleating.
And this is with bi-color paper.
It's dark on one side,
light on the other.
You get this strip of
squares in color pattern.
And then you take that strip--
a huge number of layers
in the middle, so it's
not super practical,
but it's actually pretty
efficient in terms
of how big a square
you start with.
To make an n-by-n, this
is obviously not to scale.
You need more squares here
in order to make this thing.
And then you just snake
your path back and forth.
You could use turn
gadgets, or here we're
just using 45 degree folds.
And this is pretty close
to what was believed
to be the best way to
fold a checkerboard,
and then this paper shows how
to do a factor of two better.
So we'll talk about that later.
But there are some
uses for strip folding.
This is a little
bit theoretical,
but it's actually pretty
competitive against the best
n-by-n checkerboard foldings
in the origami world,
like the one I
showed last class.
So that's practicality
of strip folding.
Next question's more
about strip folding.
There are a couple things
that are in the lecture notes,
the handwritten lecture
notes, but were not even
mentioned in the audio
part of the lecture.
So a few people asked,
what are these things?
Said pseudopolynomial
upper bound.
Pseudopolynomial is a fun term.
Let me tell you a
little bit about it.
It's from the algorithms
world, but even a lot
of algorithms people
don't know it.
So let me tell you.
So maybe first I should
tell you about polynomial.
In general, what
these terms are about
is measuring how
fast an algorithm is.
So the idea is you plot,
conceptually, n, this
is the problem size.
If you wanted to fold
an arbitrary polyhedron,
the one way to think
of the problem size
is the number vertices,
edges, and faces.
Just the total number of
things you're given as input,
and then your
output is whatever.
But n is supposed to be
the input problem size.
And then on the y-axis,
you want to plot
the running time
of your algorithm.
So this is how long it
takes to compute the way
to fold your square paper
into your desired shape,
and generally this
is going to increase.
And the question is, does it
increase in a reasonable way
or in a crazy way that
goes exponentially high?
So you want to know, how does
the running time grow with n?
Polynomial is a
sense of good growth,
and it just means
you grow, like,
n to the c, where
c is some constant.
So ideally you'd have n--
or maybe you have n squared,
or n cubed, or n to the
fourth-- all these are
considered good running times.
Not quite as good as
polynomial is pseudopolynomial.
And I would conjecture, for this
problem of folding an arbitrary
given polyhedron, you cannot
achieve a polynomial number
of folds, let's say.
So there are two things
we could measure here,
the running time of the
algorithm-- we could measure,
actually, three things--
we could measure
the number of folds you make,
the number operations you
do on the paper, and a third
thing would be scale factor.
How big a square do I have
to start with in order
to make a desired polygon?
And pseudopolynomial
means n times r to the c.
What's r?
R is some geometric parameter,
geometric ratio, in the input.
And in particular for this
problem what makes sense for r
is basically the longest length
divided by the shortest length.
This is typically
what r refers to.
This will come up in
later lectures as well.
So for example, you
take your entire shape,
you measure the diameter of the
shape, the two farthest points.
That's your longest length.
Shortest length
would be-- maybe you
have a triangle,
something like this,
in the target polyhedron
you want to make.
This would be your
shortest distance.
This is actually called
the minimum feature
size in computational geometry
or the minimum altitude
of any of your triangles.
OK, so that's just some number.
And you can have a triangle,
which is super, super narrow.
And so it's this ratio r
could be arbitrarily large
even though you only have
three vertices, three edges,
one face.
So n and r not
necessarily comparable,
so that's why in
pseudopolynomial we put them
both together, and then we raise
them to some constant power.
That's a pseudopolynomial
running time.
So the question that's
being posed here
is, can you get a
pseudopolynomial upper bound,
and can you get a
pseudopolynomial lower bound?
And it doesn't say
for what, but it's
for all three
problems-- running time,
number of folds, scale factor.
And not all of these are open.
So in the original
paper, there's
this theorem that says lots of
things-- you can fold anything.
Then it says here, the folding
requires a number of folds,
polynomial of n
and the ratio, r.
So it already claims it there
is a pseudopolynomial bound
on the number of folds.
It doesn't say what that
pseudopolynomial bound is.
Is it n times r?
Is it n plus r?
Is it n times r squared?
I would guess one of the first
two-- n times r or n plus r.
So that's the upper
bound question.
Maybe we can work on this
in a problem session.
A lower bound
question is, do you
prove that you need some
dependence, both on n and r?
Which I would guess
is pretty easy.
If you want to take a
square and fold it down
to a really, really
skinny triangle,
I think you need at
least r folds, roughly.
And similarly you should
need at least n folds,
so there should be a
lower bound like n plus r.
But none of these have been
written down explicitly,
so that's what those
open questions are.
Then there was
another slide, six,
which was completely uncovered.
Stop me if there are questions.
I should maybe take a
brief moment to breathe.
So the next part of the lecture
notes ask about seam placement.
So seam placement has the
following kind of issue.
When you fold, like this
number-- is this a six?
This is a nine.
Fold this number nine.
In addition to seeing the color
pattern, if you look closely
there's also these
kinds of seams.
This white square is
not just a white square.
You can see on the top
layer this crease line.
And here there's a seam,
here there's a seam.
These are like visible lines.
Of course, you have to have
seams at the color transitions,
but there's other seams as well.
Maybe you want to minimize
the seams you want to get,
you want to place the
scenes in a cool pattern.
When you fold
checkerboards, there's
a such thing as a seamless
checkerboard, where
every square is a
whole square paper.
There's no visible crease
lines on the top layer.
So this is an extension of
the universality result,
to also get sort of
universal seem placement.
And what the
original paper proves
is that you can place
the seams however
you want, provided the
seam regions, the regions
between the seams, are
convex polygons-- which
is almost always the case.
You look at a
typical model-- here,
the seam regions are all
rectangles and triangles.
So you could achieve
exactly this seam pattern
if you wanted it.
You could also say, oh,
here's a nice rectangle.
I'll make that a seam region.
Here's a nice rectangle,
I'll make that same region.
But you could not make
the entire number nine
here a seam region,
because it's non convex.
At least, you can't do
it with this technique.
We don't know,
necessarily, whether this
is possible by
some other folding.
I would guess no, but
it is possible to make
some non-convex seam regions.
For example I could take this
page and fold the corner over,
and now I've got a
non-convex seam region here.
So some non-convexing
regions are possible.
Open question is-- if
I give you a polygon--
we know every
polygon's possible.
Now I give you a polygon and I
subdivide it into seam regions.
Which of those are possible?
Not everything is
possible, I'm pretty sure,
though I'm not sure we
have a proof of that.
Some things like this little
heart shape are possible.
Characterize.
This another cool possible
problem for problem session.
Questions about that?
I have a little bit about the
proof of how this is done.
If you wanted to just
do convex regions.
So the general
approach here is you
want to visit all of the
regions in some order.
This is called the tour.
It's pretty easy
to just-- I mean
you're allowed to visit regions
more than once, so you just
keep going, keep trying to visit
some unvisited seam region.
When you visit a seam region,
it's a convex polygon.
So what we're going to do is
make our strip fairly wide,
actually, wide enough
to completely cover
that seam region.
And then at this
moment, we basically
need to turn to do the next one.
We know how to change the
direction of the strip using
a turn gadget.
Then we have to change
the width of the strip.
Maybe it needs to be wider.
Maybe it needs to be thinner.
And then we need to shift the
strip one way or the other.
So if we just end here, we
turn, we might be misaligned.
We need to shift it over,
expand it, then do the next one,
then turn, then shift it
over and set the right width.
Keep going like that.
OK.
That's pretty messy
and complicated,
but you can do with
these two gadgets.
Strip width gadget--
you take a strip,
and you could make it
anywhere between 1/2 and 100%
of its original width.
So the idea is you start with a
really wide strip, wide enough
to cover all the polygons.
Then you do this gadget and
keep shrinking it by half
until it's roughly
the right size.
And then when you're
almost correct,
you shrink it by a
little bit more--
here shrinking to a third.
And then you get
your shrunken strip,
and it happens right at
the line that you specify.
So you can basically on
a dime shrink your strip,
and then by doing the
reverse can grow it back.
This is maybe not with
simple folds, though.
And then the other
gadget is a shift gadget,
where you're at this position
and you want to shift up.
So that's pretty easy, you
just do two turn gadgets.
So that's at a high level how
making a desired seam pattern
works.
Go on to the next question.
A lot of people asked
about this-- and this
is an open problem that
I mentioned orally.
It's not written in the notes--
which is, can you actually
do the things we said we
can do with simple folds?
So can you get a
universal folding
of a polygon, two-color pattern
polyhedron, using simple folds?
And I thought it'd be fun to
actually work on this, here,
live, because I think
this is an easy problem.
And there's a bunch
of possible answers,
and there are even two suggested
ideas from the comments field.
So let me just remind you of
the issue, what's happening,
and then I need your input,
what's going to work here.
So general picture for the strip
method was we do one triangle,
we end here, then we do a
bunch of folds like this,
and then we end here,
maybe, and then we zigzag.
And the trouble is we've already
made this triangle over here.
When we make this triangle,
we have this excess stuff,
which I haven't drawn
very accurately.
If you recall, it looks
something like that.
Or maybe even more like that
if we use right angle turn
gadgets.
And then we want to
fold it underneath
and we're doing
that, the way I said,
with height gadget
mountain folds.
But the model's
simple folds, which
I should make more explicit.
You're not allowed to
collide during the motion.
The idea with a simple
fold is that you
should be folding
along one line segment,
and you should fold
by-- at least the model
that we defined back in the
day, I'll talk more about where
this notion comes from-- you
fold by plus or minus 180
degrees, which means
after you do the fold,
you'll be flat again.
And no collision
during the motion.
If we folded this triangle,
and then we folded this one,
and this stuff is on the
top-- we can't mountain fold.
That's not considered
a simple fold.
Now one proposal
is, could we just
make the next triangle
underneath the previous one?
A different proposal
is valley fold.
These are actually
different proposals,
because, especially
for two color patterns,
it'll make a difference.
If we valley fold
here there's going
to be some junk
on the front side,
especially if you want to
get a desired seam pattern.
But maybe we'll leave
seam patterns for later.
If you want to get
a color pattern,
you might reveal
some wrong color
when you do that valley fold.
So I haven't really thought
about this idea yet.
I think it might be good.
The idea there would
be-- so you've already
made this triangle.
You mountain fold everything.
Now when you go and
you do these zigzags,
you want to be underneath
everything that you've done.
AUDIENCE: Can you fold
the one you've already
made, like as a
unit, over the side?
And then make it and then
just put it back on top?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Different idea is you basically
fold this out of the way,
do this thing, height gadget,
and then fold it back.
Maybe.
I've wondered about that, too.
Is it's going to get a
little challenging, though.
In general, there's a
huge set of triangles,
so unless you can like go
far away, make your triangle,
and then plop it down--
maybe it's possible.
I guess we can pursue that
idea, but maybe first we
should exhaust the easier ideas.
I mean, that is definitely
plausible that that's possible.
Doing that with simple folds
and not leaving any garbage
is going to be a
little challenging,
but it might be doable.
This to me is the simplest
idea, so we should first
see if it works.
Does anyone see
problems with this plan?
I have some strips.
We could think
about what it means
to be doing a turn
gadget underneath here.
So I don't know
quite about, well,
let's suppose we
are already here.
And now maybe I do
some as the turn gadget
goes to mountain folds.
Then at 90 degrees, and then
a valley fold like that.
And then I do a mountain fold.
I think they might be OK,
because turn gadgets start
with a mountain fold.
So if you're
underneath everything,
that's going to avoid collision.
And then the valley
fold brings it back.
Again, we're using just
the space below everything
that we see.
So then we make that strip,
we keep turning around,
and then later on we're going
to mountain fold this behind,
somehow, to meet this edge.
Seems OK.
Yeah?
Question?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
I'm confused about something.
When you're doing
the turn gadget,
while the paper is above the
first triangle you go over,
you're doing a bunch
of turns where you're
taking a piece of paper up
another one, folding just that
part Is that a s--
PROFESSOR: Going from
one triangle next.
Yeah.
So we could think
about that, too.
It's very, you're right.
I mean, I'm just looking
at the turning around part
for making a single
triangle, but there's also
the turn gadget going
from here to here.
It's actually slightly
more complicated
than we've covered in
class, but not really much.
It's just a slightly
generalized turn gadget.
So you're coming here, you
basically want to turn around.
Let's just think
about a way to do it.
You could imagine first
doing a turn like this.
It's not exactly a
pure turn gadget.
And then turning around
to get to next place--
this is really hard
to do on a blackboard.
Strips just tend not
to stay together well.
OK, now we're going parallel
to the correct direction,
and then we turn back and forth.
But each of those is
just using turn gadgets.
As long as a turn
gadget works fine,
a turn gadget is going to
be a mountain fold, which
is going to go
behind everything,
and then a valley fold to bring
it to a desired direction.
Those are all using
everything behind the board.
So it seems like all
those operations are OK.
Now we should also
check the color reversal
gadget, which--
it's funny thing.
I remember everything I
did before 2000 or so,
so I still have memorized the
color reversal gadget, at least
I think so.
I should probably color
this piece of paper,
so you can see
the colors change.
I don't remember anything
I've done since 2000,
but anything up to 2000 I'm OK.
This is 1998, I think.
I remember folding lots
of-- this is ticker tape,
they use it for or
not ticker tape,
but they use this for
like adding machines.
So I think it's a 90
degree mountain fold,
then you fold up
like that, and then
you fold back down with a
mountain fold like that.
You get a color reversal.
And all of those folds we're
working behind my plane
here, so should avoid
collision with everything.
I think you could do
color reversal and turn
gadgets behind.
And so the suggestion works.
Who made this suggestion?
Good idea.
Unless there are any objections,
I think that will work.
I had a different plan, which
was to use this second idea
and set up the turn gadgets
so there is no-- when you fold
this with the valley fold,
there is no ugly colors.
So you could maybe
modify the turn gadget
to be completely solidly
colored on both sides,
but I think this is much easier.
It's probably why I didn't
write it down the notes,
but I'm not sure.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think you could also
just do a thing where you just
take it far away, because
you have a really long strip.
So you can just take
that strip, and go
to where there are no things,
fold it, and then take it out
and put it on top.
PROFESSOR: OK.
How do you do that last part?
AUDIENCE: Accordion fold
it with the right lengths.
PROFESSOR: So you have to
do it with simple folds.
That's the main,
that's the challenge.
So the idea is
you're way out here,
you have a triangle
out here, which
you want to bring over here.
Maybe I should do it like this.
You could do
something like this,
so now the triangle's over here.
Then maybe you want to
go almost all the way
here and then fold it back, and
then fold it forth, and back,
until you get your triangle
exactly where you want it.
AUDIENCE: Figure
out from the base--
PROFESSOR: It seems plausible.
AUDIENCE: --where
you need to fold it.
PROFESSOR: My only concern
would be when you do this thing,
there might be a little corner.
Depends how you fold this
thing, and then you've
got to hide that corner.
And if there's triangles
all around here,
there may not be room.
I mean, maybe if there's
triangles all around here,
it's OK to have that corner,
but maybe the triangles
are different colors.
So I do believe that
should be possible,
but I think it is a little
bit more complicated
because you have to hide
one last piece after you
get in position.
Anyway, I think there
are at least three ways
to solve this problem.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are you
allowed to unfold?
PROFESSOR: Are you
That's a good question.
I don't remember whether
the original model says
whether you're
allowed to unfold.
So if there are two versions,
simple folds and unfolds,
or just simple folds.
I don't think we actually
said unfolding is allowed.
Though we're definitely
thinking about at some point,
it's probably not in
the model as defined.
Any questions?
What's next?
This is the paper that
introduced simple folds.
It's called "When
Can You Fold a Map?"
because it originally was
motivated by map folding.
And it had a bunch of reasons
for introducing simple folds,
among them is this quote, which
if you watched L1 was in there.
I think the easiest way to
refold a roadmap is differently
and her goal was
to make it easier
to refold your
roadmap correctly.
So here's one quote from
that paper as motivation.
So it's origami motivation.
But we're also wondering
about applications,
like sheet metal bending,
cardboard folding, things
like that where you want
to manufacture things
using a machine.
And while origamists can
do complicated folds,
non-simple folds,
to make art work,
in practical
manufacturing, you want
to have the simplest
possible machine.
So if you can get away with just
simple folds, as defined here,
that would be great.
Now you don't really need, some
of these are maybe artificial.
You probably don't need
the 180 degree condition,
because most of the things
you want to fold aren't flat.
We introduced that just to keep
things simple mathematically.
But you'd like to fold along
just one segment at a time,
ideally.
You definitely don't
want collision.
You don't want
material to hit things.
Whereas in origami,
you can do tucks,
you can do things that
are not simple folds.
That's a lot harder
with a machine
that doesn't have any feedback.
So here's a very simple machine.
This is a brake folder.
We actually have a
brake folder in CC,
although this one
is Electrabrake,
so this has an electric assist.
So the idea is you slide your
sheet in, and you hold here.
You pull up, and,
in this case, he's
bending to a 90 degree angle.
You can adjust it to
different angles and so on.
There are lots of
automated machines,
it's a little hard to get
photos and videos of them,
but they're based
on this principle.
Maybe you push in
a v, and you end up
with the crease in one spot.
And you'd like to just make
a sort of conveyor belt
with lots of different
pushes and pulls
and do a bunch of
simple folds, basically,
except for this 180
degree constraint.
And so we're just
curious about what's
possible by simple
folds, and that led us
into the map
folding stuff, where
it's fairly easy
to characterize.
Other things where it's harder,
we'll see in lecture three.
I thought I'd show you
some examples of things
people make with pretty
much simple folds,
other than this 180 condition.
Out of things like--
this is folding wood.
You take a sheet of material.
You start bending
these parts up,
and you can make a little
chair, a little table.
And you could fold it
back when you're not
using your living room.
You can hide everything.
So you could imagine also
having multiple sheets,
and sometimes your
room is a living room,
other times it's-- whatever
furniture you need,
you just unfold the
appropriate thing.
That's the vision.
Here's a cute little
folding chair.
There's a huge number
of folding chairs,
but this one is pretty
much simple folds.
The one thing I'm
not sure whether it
falls under simple
folds is this fold.
You do fold along one line, but
it's in two different pieces.
I'm not sure we'd call
that a simple fold.
There's, of course, lots of
slits in the material here.
But of course it has
all the same advantages
of simple folds.
This is easy to execute
one step at time.
Here's some more
complicated design.
Some of these are
computer renderings.
Some of these are real.
Again, taking furniture
out of flat walls.
And here's some table designs.
These are sheet metal.
I like this one.
It's very simple.
Take the square of sheet
metal, put in some slips do,
some very simple folds--
boom, you've got a table.
This one's also pretty simple.
Again, here we're
folding along one line,
but it's in two
different pieces.
So is that a simple fold?
It's definitely harder
to build such a machine,
but it's doable.
Here we have something that's
definitely not a simple fold,
but it's also fairly
easy to execute.
Using a roller, you can
kind of curve one segment.
I mean, when you
go to reality, you
can change the model all
sorts of different ways
and still have
something practical.
And no one rule set is gospel.
But mathematically we have to
hone in on at least one model
at a time, and then we can
see how changing the rules
changes what you can make.
OK, next question.
This is actually about the
definition of simple folds,
so it was probably
answered already.
Is it allowed to bend the rest
of paper to get it out the way
and avoid collision?
The answer is no.
In simple folds,
at least, you're
only allowed to move
that one segment.
We have actually
lately been thinking
about a different
model, where you
do allow this, but simple folds,
you can't move other parts.
You can just move the single
hinge that you're folding.
And the end product has to
be flat, yes, in our model.
Though, it would be
interesting to think
without this condition,
because you're doing 180 degree
operations before
you do the next one,
you'll be flat at all times.
1D or 2D, according
to whether you
started with a 1D piece of
paper or 2D piece of paper.
OK.
The second half of the
lecture was basically
about proving, characterizing
flat foldability
of 1D segments.
And it showed in particular
that simple folds are universal,
that if you have some
mountain valley pattern,
and it's foldable at all,
if it's flat foldable,
it will be flat foldable
via simple folds.
And in particular using
crimps and n folds.
And it was a bit
of a messy prove,
partly because I've made a
mistake in lecture, as you saw.
I kind of corrected
for it on the fly,
but it's maybe not
the best written.
So I wanted to go through
a couple quick examples
to make clear all
the issues there.
So here are the ones I prepared.
We can certainly do more
if it's still not clear.
So here's a simple
mountain-valley pattern,
and it's got some long
segments and, let's just
say, equidistant segments here.
Three valleys, then a mountain.
So first question
is, is this mingling?
And then the ultimate question
is, is it flat foldable?
So is it mingling?
Well, maybe you
could answer for me.
Just yes or no.
50% chance.
So maybe the definition of
mingling is not super clear.
Let me review it.
So you look at each,
I mean, generally
of a sequence of
mountains and valleys,
you look at a chunk
of all valleys,
then you look at a
chunk of all mountains,
and chunk of all valleys.
Here there's only two chunks--
three valleys and one mountain.
And the definition is a little
awkward for a single crease,
but let's start
with the valleys.
The point is to check-- for
the first segment between two
valleys versus the segment just
before it, which is bigger?
And this is the bad case this
is the non-mingling situation,
because this thing
is bigger than this.
Strictly bigger, the notation
we use in the lecture
is an open square bracket.
So square bracket meant
that this is bigger.
Round bracket would mean this
is less than or equal to this.
That's just the definition.
Over on this side
of the valleys,
this length is equal
to this length.
So the last distance
between two values
is equal to the
one right after it.
And that's a good case, so we
write a closed, round bracket.
Then we have a
sequence of mountains,
and here it's a
little confusing,
but it's the same idea.
So this is the very
first mountain.
You look at the length right
after it versus the length
right before it,
and this is smaller.
And that's a good case.
We write an open, round bracket
for this mountain group.
And then same thing.
Now we're comparing
the same two distances,
but it's now bad, because
this one is strictly longer
than this one.
So we write a closed,
square bracket.
So that's the notation
in this example.
Any questions about that?
So you just have to
check-- in general,
you have a whole group of
valleys-- these are all
valleys, or all
mountains-- and you
want to compare this
one versus this one.
And square or closed,
according to which is bigger.
And you want to look at the last
one versus the after last one.
So that's the notation.
And the point of the proof
was to argue that, either
if you're going to be
flat foldable at all,
actually if you're
mingling-- mingling meant
that for each of these
intervals, at least one
of the sides was round.
That was considered good.
So this crease
pattern is mingling,
because there's two regions.
This one has a round bracket.
And what we argue is
it if you're mingling,
which was necessary, if
you're flat foldable,
you have to be mingling.
It's a necessary but
not sufficient condition
for flat foldability.
If you're mingling,
either you have a pattern
like this, close round
bracket, open round bracket.
That's good because this
is a crimp that you can do.
You see it up here.
This is a crimp.
You valley fold, mountain fold,
and you don't hide anything
when you make that operation.
Or there's an end fold, which
corresponded to an open round
bracket at the
beginning or closed
round bracket at the end.
So here there's a crimp.
Let's do the crimp.
So when we do the crimp, let's
keep this part of paper fixed.
So this we go over
to here, hopefully,
then we valley fold,
then we mountain fold,
and we keep going from there.
That segment is that segment.
So we still have this valley.
This was a valley
we just folded.
This is the mountain
Now conceptually, we just
sort of fuse this back
into the paper, because
those creases are done.
We don't need to
think about them.
The point is, in that region
there were no extra creases.
These round parentheses
will guarantee
there's nothing here, no
creases here, here, or here.
Could be creases farther away
but by these inequalities,
that this length is less
than or equal to this one,
and this length is less
than or equal to this one.
Sorry, greater than or equal to.
Then you know this is OK.
So there's two valleys left.
So now we have two valleys,
we have a long segment,
and a long segment.
And this is something
that can't be made.
Because there's no folded
state of this thing,
never mind simple folds, because
it's going to cross like that.
So this is not flat foldable.
It's also not mingling,
because if you
look at these two valleys--
You look at the
distance over here.
It's bigger than this
one, so that's bad,
so you have an open
square bracket.
And this one is also bigger than
this, imagine these as fused,
and so it's a closed
square bracket.
And so this group of
values is not mingling.
So it's not mingling.
So ultimately this
pattern we started
with is not flat foldable,
because one of the things we
proved is doing a crimp never
changes flat foldability.
It's always a safe thing to do.
You might wonder,
oh, maybe there's
some other fold I could to
do that eventually works,
but we proved crimps
are always safe to do.
So we did it, and we got stock.
That means this was
not flat foldable,
even though it was mingling.
And so the mingling
forever property just
means, if it's mingling
and then you do a crimp,
and it's still mingling, and
if you keep doing crimps,
and it stays
mingling all the way,
then you were flat foldable.
It's not a very satisfying
characterization,
but it is a thing.
Maybe I'll do one more
example where it works,
so we're super clear.
Whoa, we're out of time, so
I won't do another example.
All right, ambitious.
I gotta work on my timing.
There are a
Couple other fun questions here.
I would encourage you to
read the notes about them.
In particular, there's
an algorithmic question.
How do you actually
compute this efficiently?
You could do it very
efficiently in linear time.
So n, where c is one, just n
time-- instead of n squared
or something-- using
a pretty simple idea.
Basically just look
for the first crimp,
do it, and then see if
there are crimps nearby,
and keep going
forward, and you can
prove that it takes linear time.
There is this fun question
I enjoy thinking about.
Can you make any mountain-valley
pattern flat foldable
by adding creases?
The answer is yes.
You can think of it as a puzzle.
There is one proposed
way to do it here.
I have another one in the notes.
You can think about it.
And the last
question, is what does
it possibly mean to fold
something in four dimensions?
How do you imagine it?
Hard to imagine, but
you can think about it.
You have a d-dimensional
piece of paper,
you fold it through
d plus 1 dimensions.
If you want it flat folded, it
ends up back in d dimensions,
and your creases are
d minus 1 dimensional.
And the rest you just
have to visualize.
I have one example
folding a solid cube
in half in the notes.
That's certainly possible.
That's not very well
studied, and there's
lots of interesting
open questions
about higher
dimensional folding.
Any questions before we go?
All right.
Watch lecture three, and
please send your feedback.
It was really helpful.